no piece on the road and with there's
always roadblocks and please how long do
you think you're going to stay as
president for as long as the people want
me to stay you've actually got a general
on the television you might not call it
a coup but it's a coup
[Applause]
these are the first few minutes of a new
presidency in Zimbabwe
that in itself is unusual for to seeing
armored personnel carriers and fully
armed soldiers taking up positions on
street corners in Harare
send every single ounce of the world
that this was something big happening
here I was filming secretively the AP
C's armored personnel carriers on the
roads and I was thinking oh that's never
happened before
might be something here on the right
hand side is a tape you see in the
bushes
I dare this okay our store was very
suspicious I was thinking no no you know
mcgaubey is he's been in here he's been
here before
and he's always he's always come through
it that classic thing you've actually
got a general on the television
comrade ROG Mugabe and his family are
safe and sound and their security is
guaranteed he might have coeliac oh but
it's okay
within a day it started to change
[Applause]
and people began to say well hold on are
we talking about the end here
is this is this it and people then took
to the street jubilant celebrations the
army weren't doing anything they weren't
stopping people almost unheard of well
finally be able to say we're free we're
open we've got you know look at us we're
all together blacks whites unify
together that was the first time that I
thought hang on it is changed something
is going to give you and it looks like
it's going to be Maga be it's quite
emotional thing just to be part of of
this and I pulled my camera and I
thought no I'm gonna capture us I could
deal with the consequences and I
captured these moments of people
desperate for change Robert Mugabe had
become a very controversial figure he
gave very few face to face interviews
about a decade ago we were fortunate
enough to be able to interview why is
still having to point up difference
between blacks and white because then
the whites is still contemptuous still
racist and we don't want that in our
society what really struck all of us who
were there was his absolute conviction
that what he was doing was right and
that it was outside forces that had been
against the country against him and
against black people and I remember our
producer saying mr. peasant d-minor we
have a photo with you and I remember all
of us lining up thinking this is
incredible there's a photo of me
clipping on a lapel mic on to President
Mugabe's tie and thinking I'm a word I
can't believe I'm actually touching this
bloke and he wasn't scared of the
foreign journalists he didn't give a
damn how long do you think you're going
to stay as president for as long as the
people want me to stay
but not for you - me - of course the
state had become a violent torturing
nasty organisation with Robert Mugabe oh
it's at its head until in the end they
decided on us enough Zimbabwe never
thought it but perhaps they should thank
grace because she definitely brought
about the enemy grace Maccabi can't
quite figure and she was attracted to
what being married to the president
could bring she began to surround
herself with people who were closer from
the Garbi and she wanted to have her own
potential place as the vice president
then a future president
Emerson Managua was his deputy
eventually he realized he'd been taken
out of office grace will of course would
have been involved in this
at this stage also the spending you know
Gucci grace as he was called was worse
sort of out of control this sort of
ostentatious lifestyle was seriously
beginning to irritate senior members who
weren't part of her clique including the
military the sacking of Managua who was
fundamentally supported by the military
was the end for Robin mcGarvie the
streets filled with people thinking this
is the new change this is actually only
known the rule and this means no jobs no
opportunities go on to you would make
the same mistakes new people new
government there was incredible we were
absolutely mobbed people weren't such a
celebratory mood
[Applause]
and I'll tell you it was the most
euphoric monitor that I've ever
experienced Muslim Bob way forming
experiences the feeling on the streets
where things are going to get better
hysterical exaltation that this was the
beginning of the new Zimbabwe and that
it was a new change was going to happen
[Music]
there was a sense that inauguration
would take place in this a hugely
significant it was like going to a sort
of like a cup final you could hear the
stadium people from all over were just
converging on the stadium they were
loving and absolutely loving it loving
the fact that we were there the fact
that we were in an open filming that we
weren't in a danger we were walking past
police and talking to the police video
section getting directions from which
way we should go to get into the stove
[Music]
the sense of a new change
new people are amazing we all decided to
go up the steps to have a look at what
it was like
reaction when we would just weigh the
people and the whole fans would wave
back they were clearly just proud to be
and I was too I have to say I was
somewhat moved
[Applause]
[Music]
finally walking into the football field
and just looking at this and singing
I've never thought this way I never
thought I would see this we're rolling
the Garvey has stood down and that a new
president is being sworn in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
great fantastic music in clay fantastic
military bands nothing like we'd ever
have in the UK and people chanting and
singing revolutionary songs then man
agogo your team
[Applause]
and it was utter hysteria
it was like this is the new beginning
and this is the guy I couldn't believe
how close I could get to the newly
appointed president was just amazing and
in that very African way which is lovely
you could actually be standing bit of
just next to him I think I was you know
I was taught the 3rd to be touching the
podium and as he was being sworn
as itself
very happy very pleased the question is
crowd be pleased as well in the future
will it bring about major political
change there's an awful lot of people
are very very doubtful but these are the
first few minutes of a new presidency in
Zimbabwe
and the reaction from everyone who was
watching was the mixture of of laughter
and tears
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in but having a monopod which is a
long pole my camera attached the name I
was in the tree leaning it over his head
thinking wow I'm living history I'm
being part of this most incredible
historic moment at KU that's taking
place you've got the new president
sitting down and then the either sides
his ranks and ranks of soldiers all
pleased to be paying their respects and
showing exactly where who support he has
when the head of the police came and the
whole stadium boot
was amazing you couldn't hear anything
being said between them now when they
would think it was utterly drowned out
they couldn't have done it a short while
ago they couldn't have booed the head of
the police without retribution being
swift and it really was that one moment
you thought wow is it possible this has
changed
certainly it's changed enough for them
to do this maybe there is a big change
there was a 21 gun salute when man and
God were marched along inspecting the
troops I was sprinting around in between
these troops and having the most
incredible access
[Music]
there's a sense that it's just a chance
that them could be changed
everyone wanted to talk everyone wanted
to say that there is going to be changed
that this is a new beginning things did
happen that surprised me in a positive
way and they're saying that there will
be elections in the corns with a
constitution I suspect they will take
place but what structures will be put in
place to make sure they are free and
fair Maga be bought with him this
historic issues for years and years is
one dictator has gone perhaps he's been
replaced by a dictator light
I don't want to be pessimistic about
this but you're the initial noises the
personnel what's happened how things
have moved doesn't bode awfully well but
we could be proved wrong
[Music]